αλλά και του λιμανιού της πολις άρα πρέπει α ναι δύο παραλέ τις διαικασίες έργα
και ι διαδικασία ξέύρεσης ενώς επενδιτή που αυτή τη φορά θελοπιση του ργο και ίσως
κάπου πρέπει να δούμε και τι προσδοκίας μας με αυτόν το εργό γιατί να με
τον ναβάζ δο προσδογίες και μετάν αρχε το πειδρί και να που λέεγι η τελικά
δεν μπορά το κανού καλύτερα να κάπο κάτι πιο ορειαλιστικών και κάτι που θα βοηθήσει
περισότερο την πόλη έτσι ώστε να πειτύχουμε αυτόν τος στηματικός το όπως πετύχαμε άλλους στηματικούς
πτοχούς γιατί κανένας δεν πιστεύουν ι θα φύγον τις εξαμενέες αίτες φύγαμε κανάς δεν μι
στεπεν ότι θα είνουν ερ κα τόστον εκατοπηρός τελάν να κάτο καταφέραμε ξενοδοχία διοτικίς αναπτύ
ρα θέρω από ότι δεν υπάρχει τήπο τα κατορθότο φάνει να βάλει στους στόους του
ρεαλιστικούς και με ένα στηνγκεκριμώνών οδικό χαρτη πος τος πετυχέντης τν αβάγειωση ότι αφορά ότη
μαρίνα και το λημάνι έφερε κάποια στά σημότητα σε ότι αφορά και ι κακάταψέματα την
περίοδο που υπήρχαν και κάποια έργα στην περιοχή υπήρχε συνέχω ενδιαφέρον απο πενητές από ξένους
να αγοράσουν σπίτια διαμερίσματα αυτόν πήγα κάπος πίσω πουίκαξε μια απογοίδευση υπιξην δεν μποροαπό ότι
την επιρξαπό τευσεπρώτα ι όλα εμείς ίδγιατί εμεί είμαστε υτή που αλεψηαε περισότρο αθεω πόλου
να πειτχι του έργο δλαδί αν αν δει στις υρεντευσης και των επενδιτών και τις
κυβέρν εσείς θα λέει ότι ο μόνος θεσμός ο μόνος φορέίας ο οποίος ανετα πάντα
αναπειτύει αυτή κιπεντις ενήμο μενώ πό το παραδέχουνται όλοι ότι εμείς καάε περισσότερα π αυτά
που επρέπε να τους φέρουμε κοντά να προχωρσει του έργον ι αδιοδοτήσεις στα πάντα εμείς
προσπαθεί ναμε πάρα πολύ να πειτύχει αυτό το υτόν το εργόν αλλά θέουν από ότι
οι αριθμί δείχνουν ότι πέίρν από τί να αρχήκή να ποίδευση και έτσι την το
κλίματο οποίο δημουργήθηκε είναι ότι δεν φάνηκε ότι έχουν επηρεάσει την ανάπτυξη τη λάρνακας αντιθέτος
ι αράπτυξη συνεχίζεται νέα έργα νέα ξενο τοχία στων τουρισμόν πλέον ια αριθμί δείχνουν ότι
είμαστε νονούμεο τρία προρισμός τουριστών στην κύπρον αυτό ν εθι μελέτες πέρση ανδί σταπολιτήρια έγραφα
δης την απασχόληση όλοι οι δείκτε στη λέρα να κανατευτέ χρονια εα ενανοδική και συνεχίζουντα
εννωτική θεωρείται το αντιλαμβάνεστε και σεις εκεί στον δήμο ότι